all right big big news afternoon even
after we finished today's program just a
lot of news breaking we'll talk about
yet another accuser against Roy Moore
who's running for Senate in not Arizona
Alabama trying to win jeff sessions is
former seat
we will talk about just so much going on
I've got some other stories I want to
talk about we have this breaking story
about wiki mails released which
implicate wiki leaks and Donald Trump
jr. in collusion in what could be just a
blockbuster bombshell story a lot going
on so I'm glad you're with me today it's
been a little while since the last
livestream I think was it was it
Wednesday or actually it might have been
just Monday last week last week was a
busy week I was out of town from
Wednesday on so anyway we're here now
and that's what matters I will have
Jenga updates I will have all sorts of
stuff before I do even get going though
before the stream as you can see up here
there was a hundred-dollar contribution
made by rappleyea or Apple yeah I'm not
sure how to how to pronounce it who said
we Trump stirs could use it on a social
democrat party I am from the 60s even
drafted combat Vietnam by comparison
these times are like paradise so baby
and Tifa fascists amuse me I helped
organize demonstrations a quarter
million strong all right well an
incredible story and thank you for the
hundred dollar contribution through
stream labs and on that note I will give
a quick welcome to people who haven't
been on a live stream with me before
these are live unless they're not right
now we're live if it's 6:30 1:00 p.m.
Eastern Time on November 13 2017 there's
two ways to ask questions and send
comments that I will read and react to
one is using super chat that's the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window the other is stream labs at
stream labs comm slash the david pakman
show link in the description the benefit
of stream Labs is just that we don't pay
the thirty percent cut to youtube when
you use
/ chat but by all means use either use
whichever is more comfortable for you
new patrons and members will get
recognition from me during the stream if
you sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show we now accept cryptocurrency
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin at david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency and
please do not troll we have a number of
moderators checking out what's going on
we have Daniel Smeltzer and Lauren
Thomas is here and everybody is fully
empowered and deputized to keep the
trolling only to the subtle trolling the
obvious trolling will get you blocked or
banned I will give you a Jenga update
this was from today's show and as you
can see getting very very unstable
incredibly unstable and of course we did
last week have the hair show I will talk
about that and I will talk about what's
upcoming on patreon so a lot of
different stuff going on but let's get
right into the Roy Moore story because
this is the big breaking story so
backstory is I mean it depends how far
back we want to go but going back
decades Republican Roy Moore is a really
creepy not a good guy right Roy Moore is
a sort of a sleaze ball and we've known
that for a long time
great no no big mystery there we learn
that Roy Moore is running against Doug
Jones trying to vying for Jeff Sessions
is now vacated Alabama Senate seat and
we knew Roy Moore wasn't a good guy
because he once said that the First
Amendment applies only to Christians he
once said that he believed he would
maybe one day end up giving his life to
prevent gay marriage which would be such
a stupid and pointless way to lose your
life I mean could gimme a break
and long story short he's an extreme
ideological conservative over the
weekend or late last week it breaks that
a 14 year old girl says hey Roy Moore
when he was 32 sexually assaulted me and
of course it's a disaster it implodes
immediately you have two Republicans
defending more you have more denying it
but say yes I did date sixteen year olds
with the permission of their parents but
never a 14-year old and of course it's
kind of crazy to think that I mean look
let's just think about
most 32 year-olds wouldn't date a 16
year old if you're 32 and you would date
a 16 year old and readily admit that on
national media as he did to Sean Hannity
once you say I am a did a guy who in his
thirties dated 16 year olds it's not
hard to believe that you would also date
a 14 year old or at least try to write
so that that number one is is all pretty
pretty believable and straightforward
but then today we learned of yet another
accuser there is yet another woman who
is now accusing now a woman was then 15
years old who says Roy more sexually
assaulted me when I was 15 years old and
her name is Beverly Nelson young she's
of Alabama she says that she used to
work at the Old Hickory house she was a
waitress there Roy Moore would come in
one day her boyfriend was late picking
her up
so Moore offered her a ride home and
when she got in the car instead of
driving her home as she tells the story
more drove behind the restaurant parked
the car and sexually assaulted her
without her consent while she struggled
and protested and of course
right-wingers are focusing on the fact
that Gloria Allred is representing the
the victim and people saying Gloria
Allred is a feminist bomb thrower Gloria
Allred is responsible for the eventual
passage of roe v wade and the eventual
murders of millions and children through
abortion and of course the truth is that
whatever Gloria Allred's position and
influence on roe v wade forty years ago
that has no bearing whatsoever on
whether this this victim story is true
and the the allegations now are building
in such a way that Republican Lindsey
Graham is saying that grow more needs to
get out of there more and more
Republicans calling for Roy Moore to
step aside and you know what I can't
help but go back to is Roy Moore should
step aside by the way and in a way I
don't I'm not so concerned with whether
Roy Moore steps aside or not I'm more
interested in what will be the path that
makes sure he doesn't end up away
because there are a lot of evangelicals
who are saying after the first
allegations against Roy Moore that they
are more likely to vote for more since
learning of the sexual assault
allegations against him so that that
mean that that's insane
but what it tells us is that these
so-called moral majority voters these
evangelical Christians it's never
actually about the principles and doing
the pro-family thing and doing the right
thing it's about winning elections and
it's about imposing their Christian
worldview on everybody else and if they
just admitted that if they said you know
we claim to be morally superior and and
to be with God but the truth is we don't
even really care about that because Roy
Moore is now accused by multiple
children of sexual assault and we're
still gonna vote for the guy just admit
it right just be upfront and say what we
really want is Christian dominionist
types like Roy Moore representing us
just be upfront just say that's what we
want and I would actually have more
respect for them because the entire game
where it's all about being with God and
being Jesus like and doing the right
thing it's all [ __ ] right it's all
[ __ ] and it's all about who can we
get in power that will try to put a ten
a ten commandments monument on federal
state grounds which Roy Moore tried to
do who can we get elected who will try
to defy the supreme court to prevent gay
marriage which Roy Moore did and
ultimately ended up having to resign
after being sanctioned for that right so
that is really what they want and I'm
not surprised about this these are
credible allegations in the sense that
there is absolutely no reason whatsoever
to believe that these are individuals
who are making this up I believe that
the the victim the the degree to which
some automatically are questioned those
who denounce sexual assault given all
the stigma and all of the repercussions
that exist in society when someone comes
out and says hey this is what happened
to me that that's that's not where I am
right so I'm not there I think that
these are absolutely credible accusers
and
there's nothing I mean he has a history
of being against a strict punishment for
those who commit statutory rape as a
judge he admits to having dated sixteen
year old so it's not there's nothing
shocking about this that's just it's
just the reality and by the way when
we're talking about sexual assault
there are now six women accusing former
President George HW Bush of groping them
all on on the ass or buttocks depending
on what vocabulary you prefer to use and
the latest as a kid right we now have a
woman who now a woman who was a 16 year
old kid back in 2003 when she was
photographed next to George HW Bush and
says he grabbed her buttocks and she is
now the sixth woman who said that and
it's not even really being denied the
George HW Bush camp is defending it by
saying it's kind of a bunk Uhler they're
writing it off as a bunk you learn I
know that's not a word that everybody
uses a bunk Euler means sort of other
resembling that which an uncle would do
this sort of familial oh good old Shosh
ox type of stuff but that is it's a it's
an affirmative defense in other words
they're saying yeah he grabs people he
Pat's women's butts or as the women
describe it he grabs and gropes but it's
just this friendly thing that he does so
I don't know what's ultimately going to
happen with the George HW Bush thing I
mean I don't think there's even the
possibility of anything criminal going
on we're talking about a 93 year old and
actually I think the best explanation is
dementia I don't believe that George HW
Bush was accused of doing this stuff
before he was I mean in this case we're
talking about almost 80 years old and
the sort of hypersexuality thing is very
common in people with sometimes we're
talking about subclinical dementia so it
doesn't mean that they are suffering
from it from extreme dementia sometimes
it's subclinical meaning it wouldn't be
diagnosed as such but the hypersexuality
can happen and we'll listen we don't
know I'm not defending his actions
whatsoever but it does feel different
than some of these
other allegations that that we are
seeing doesn't excuse them in any way
whatsoever but I think you know not
louis c.k is not the same as Harvey
Weinstein is not the same as Bill Cosby
is not to say these are all unique
circumstances and all have their nuances
and ins and outs so we'll be talking
about that on the program tomorrow also
I believe that tomorrow the Jenga tower
is going to fall we are now up we've
made 26 moves and what we're doing is
for every two patreon contributions I
play a piece on the Jenga tower that's
on my desk and I was convinced that we
were gonna lose it today and that it was
going to fall and I was successfully
able to make 26 moves which correlates
to we're basically gonna do a membership
special where we take the number of
moves and double it and that becomes the
that becomes the membership discount so
26 moves so far has a 52 percent
discount if we get a few more
contributions today I can only imagine
that tomorrow this thing is going down
you can already see how top-heavy it is
and at the bottom it's resting on just
two Jenga pieces and sort of a plus sign
orientation so it's getting down to the
wire and I'm worried it will actually
fall when I'm not even moving pieces
just when I'm doing other stories
because it is so unstable right now but
the moment it comes crashing down and
makes a huge noise and the pieces
explode everywhere that's going to be an
amazing moment on the program a first
for sure so please make those
contributions at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and I'll do another little
little challenge which is we started the
evening at 2076 patrons if we can get to
2100 which is just 24 more I'll create a
55 percent membership discount code for
you and announce it just on the stream
and thanks to the the generous
contribution of Spencer grape who has
pledged $2 a month just a minute or two
ago we're now at 2077 if we get just 23
contributions there I will create and
release for you a 55 percent membership
discount code and I can only imagine by
the way if we get to 2,100 patrons the
Jenga tower is going down tomorrow I
don't see any way around it
whatsoever let's dig into some of the
super chat & stream labs questions
Mariano Cardozo sent a ten-dollar super
chat with no question or comment just
sending a contribution appreciate it
very much
over at stream labs.com / the david
pakman show gigantic has sent a $4
contribution asking sargon of akkad vs.
david pakman drunken peasants debate
when yeah so listen I've agreed to
debate sargon of akkad I call him Karl
Benjamin I agreed on Twitter to debate
him on the drunken peasants podcast or
live stream the only thing I said was we
need to have specific topics and
duration right I'm not interested in
just a misleading for three hours on
twelve different topics let's pick some
topics that I'm actually passionate
about and let's debate those I've not
been contacted by anyone from the
drunken peasants so far so if you were
hoping that that I had a date for you
not only has nothing been scheduled but
I've not even been contacted by anybody
at the drunken peasants other than that
public tweet from TJ Kirk amazing
atheist saying I'd like to get these two
to debate so yeah it hasn't been
scheduled yet and I don't know when it
will be but I'm willing to debate a
Vladimir Alexandrov has sent two $5.00
stream Labs contributions dream labs
calm / the David Pakman show hey David
last night Dave Rubin on Fox News went
after people who criticized Trump
calling them crazy and with mental
condition and having a trump derangement
syndrome is it fair to call him a Trump
apologist at this point yeah it is
it is and you can be a trump apologist
regardless of your personal politics
right so Dave Rubin this is not a
critique or an analysis of Dave Reubens
politics you could be progressive all
the way to conservative and you can be
an apologist for anything and Donald
Trump is an example of that and yeah I
mean at this point it when I saw that
and it was it was disturbing to me
because he seemed he he's clearly
playing a character on that show and
what I mean by playing a character is
not that he's not representing who he
genuinely is right he may be and he may
not the persona that Dave Rubin played
yesterday or whenever it was on Greg
Gutfeld show on Fox News it was a
designed persona in the sense that he's
there to offer up a let's not get crazy
about Trump the world is still standing
people are deranged about Trump whatever
and that may line up with his personal
politics it may not you know at this
point when you look at the program that
he does I really couldn't tell you what
his personal politics are are they the
ones that are reflected on his show is
that a concocted character in order to
appeal to the the individuals that are
funding his program I don't know and and
you know that that's something that I
really take pride that on our program
I've never had a significant sort of
upheaval in terms of my politics right
I've talked about issues over time where
as I've become educated my views have
changed so I was always sort of socially
very very liberal but there was a time
that I bought into and I'm gonna talk
about this later on this week and a
question audience question that we have
there was a time that I bought into
supply-side trickle-down economics
because I had only been exposed and
educated by sort of traditional and
rational actor neoclassical economics
and overtime as I learned more as I
educated myself about behavioral
economics and other other academic
disciplines I learned that trickle-down
economics doesn't work so my views on
that have evolved right I've said that
my views on transgenderism have evolved
over time where there was a time where I
think I was less than completely
empathetic to two transgender
individuals and over time I've become
more educated but the thing is these
have been smaller shifts and they didn't
happen in my 30s right they happened
like when I got out of high school and
became more educated in critical
thinking and in other disciplines so you
know one thing you can be sure of is
that there are no there are no hidden
forces funding the program I'm very
clear were funded by
membership were funded by patreon and
the great thing about those is that no
one person funds us enough that they
could influence what I do right we don't
have any institutions whatever they
might be and this applies to Dave Rubin
or whoever else we don't have any
institutions that are sending us guests
or giving us money or doing anything
it's just a reflection of what I want I
pick the guests I pick the stories and
that's it you know so there's there's
never going to be that question as to
has David Pakman changed his perspective
because he's getting big money or
moderate money or money from some
institution that's imposing their
worldview on him because it's just
patrons right Spencer Graef just
contributed two bucks a month on patreon
I love him for it and he's gonna get all
the member perks and patreon perks or
you know whatever it is that he signs up
for but I'll be totally upfront Spencer
can influence the production of the show
Spencer emails me and people have in the
end Spencer says hey David I really
don't like your coverage of this I'll
pull my two bucks a month if you don't
say something else I'll say bye Spencer
because that's not how the show works
right the support we have is support of
the format and the idea of the David
Pakman show but it's not here for us to
tout libertarian or conservative or neo
liberal or pro or anti anything ideology
the show reflects my views and that's it
anyway a little bit of a rant there but
yeah that that Vladimir that was a
disturbing appearance by Dave Rubin I
was really distraught by it actually and
you can there's a link to it and a
discussion on our our reddit david
pakman.com slash reddit purchase
westbrook's has sent a dollar
contribution at stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show saying merely love
the show thanks purchase very much
appreciate your support and then back
over to super chat Paul McGinnis
puppetry Paul McGinnis puppetry has sent
a $2 super chat what scare you scares
you the most
is it global warming I don't know it's
hard for me to say one thing global
warming what I'm scared about with
global warming is that while I believe
humans do have the power and knowledge
to fix it what scares me is that we're
going to because people aren't going to
take it seriously enough and the climate
deniers and the fossil fuel ores and all
of them are going to get in the way so I
am concerned by the lack of urgency
around climate change
I am scared about the United States
moving further into these authoritarian
listen look at who Trump's friends are
right Rodrigo Duterte who admits to just
killing people on wins on the street
president air Dhawan of Turkey is
someone that not a friend of crumpet
someone Trump thinks has done a great
job in many ways Vladimir Putin right
Trump's friends are all the
authoritarian dictators for the for the
most part and he even said he would like
to be friends with Kim jong-un although
that was a bizarre sort of strange tweet
so my concern is that anti and
pseudo-intellectual ism is going to lead
us more in the direction of having this
low information voting bloc that is
influenced by the populist sounding
language of folks like Trump who are a
combination of clueless and
authoritarian in their tendencies and
that we're going to keep moving in that
direction that really scares me and I
don't know what it's going to take to
turn that around but it's it's bad it is
bad and I don't want it for a moment to
understate the the possible disastrous
influence of that let me say thank you
to a few new members this is something I
like to do during the live streams I
like to thank everybody that
participates in supporting the program
financially in some way shape or form
but when people sign up for membership
during the streams I like to say thank
you because it means a lot
dan lee has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Kenneth
Harrison Kenneth Harrison who I think
goes by Ken actually if I recall
correctly has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership lauren asher
thank you for becoming a member at david
pakman.com slash membership and Diana
Whitmore has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership if you don't
like the normal membership rates take
the discount we've got a discount code
which is I voted 17 you can
it whenever you want to get a discount
off of membership you get all the great
member benefits which include that every
day a lot of people don't know this
every single day we do an hour broadcast
show which is what gets chopped up and
put on YouTube but then we do an extra
show an extra 15 sometimes even longer
minute show just for our members and
it's available to patrons at the $5 or
greater level and it's available to all
members very very exciting and people
love the the bonus show here's a little
behind-the-scenes peek generally
producer Pat picks the stories for the
bonus show I will email him stories I
want on the bonus show but it's usually
just three or four stories a week so of
the roughly 15 stories on the bonus show
Pat is selecting most of them and that's
a great thing
all right so let's do it make it let's
make it happen and sign up thank yous
for coming a couple other super chats
here Brian Finley says what's your take
on the George Takei controversy yeah
George Takei famed Star Trek actor and
Howard Stern Show announcer has made has
has been has received allegations of
sexual assault and the details are a
little bit hazy to me but they do come
from an individual that George Takei
says he doesn't know I genuinely don't
know what to make of them I read one
analysis saying that these are very
disturbing allegations which of course
they are and I saw another analysis
saying it's just not believable I don't
really know I mean I'm trying to put
aside my sort of favorable view of
George Takei but I have absolutely no
idea I mean like with all these claims
my instinct is always to say I don't
distrust accusers I tend to think that
making an allegation of sexual assault
is a big deal and that when someone does
it we should take it seriously but I
don't know what else to tell you it's
very disturbing
that's for sure I'm being told that
although we're getting animations down
here when people donate that people's
names aren't showing up up here let me
do a test here let's do a test super
chat so it shows up here but yeah it's
not showing up up there I wonder why
that is I'm gonna have to do some kind
of test of that why would it not be
showing up seems like everything's
enabled
oh no let's do a test donation hmmm
showing up down here but not up there I
don't know why that is that's very very
weird all right I think I'm gonna leave
that for now the donations are working
and that's an important thing I'll try
to get that fixed before the next before
the next livestream a CW hambone has
sent a four dollar and twenty cent
stream Labs contribution at stream labs
comm slash the David Pakman show
hey David is there a specific topic for
your interview with Jesse Lee Peterson
how do you plan to deal with his
dishonesty and inability to understand
basic concepts the guy calls Trump the
great white hope and has been
championing more as a great Christian
yeah so I don't even know where to start
with this some months ago I appeared on
the Jesse Lee Peterson program at the
time it was just a radio and online show
the program has since been picked up by
Newsmax TV which is a disturbing
development but during the last
interview yeah like he couldn't really
understand anything I was saying I was
trying to ask him to present some
evidence to defend the crazy assertions
he was making about the protestors at
the women's March being left-wing funded
astroturf type of stuff and it didn't go
particularly well but the video clip did
really well on our YouTube channel
because it was just so outrageous and
Mike the condition I placed on going on
there was that I need to be allowed to
put it on my youtube channel and they
said sure they've invited me back and
this time the subject matter is going to
be political correctness and
I I don't know what the other topic is
but yeah I'm gonna be back on Wednesday
morning and this time it'll be on news
max it's gonna be all over the place and
I'm going back on just for entertainment
value I just find it crazy that this guy
has a show and I look forward to putting
it up for everybody to see I know not
all of you not all of my audience
watches news max but it's going to be a
doozy it's gonna be an incredible
incredible an interview for sure any
ghost has sent a $20.00 stream lapse
contribution David what will you do when
all of the paths come forward with their
allegations against you I don't blame
you now bye Pat's I don't know if you
mean like producer Pat's because there's
only one or the Patriots but I believe
that I will not have sexual assault
allegations against me nameless King
sent a $2.00 stream lapse contribution
are you aware of any fans that supported
Trump at some point and what do you
think of the rise of right-wing
libertarianism in the United States
listen I know that there are David
Pakman show viewers I guess they would
be fans who supported Trump voted for
Trump and they have different reasons
for doing so some are more extreme
trumpets and I guess I'd be less
inclined to call them fans they would be
viewers but there's people who say they
like the show and they ended up voting
for Trump they were mostly X Bernie
supporters and statistically I don't
think that the Bernie to Trump vote was
it was a big vote in the election but
they do exist and some of them have
called into the show so yeah I think
that there are some in the audience and
what do I think of right-wing
libertarianism in the United States well
I think it's horrible I think that the
the rise of only mildly informed
right-wing libertarianism is a
concerning development I don't like it
and I'm gonna do everything I can to to
fight it people saying in the regular
chat that I should get to the gym I just
got back from the gym just got back from
the gym so thank you very much
Betty Knight has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat with no
you know comment thanks very much I
appreciate that always appreciate super
chats and stream labs contributions
whether or not they have any money
attached and on that note let me do
another patreon thank you thanks to
Scott Pyle Scott Pyle has sent a has
pledged $2 a month at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show so listen
three different things to talk about
when it comes to patreon number one is
that if tonight we get to 2100 patrons I
will create and announce for you a 55
percent membership discount code won't
tell anybody else about it won't mention
it on the podcast won't mention it on
YouTube won't mention it anywhere except
to you and you can save fifty five
percent off of membership ok that's if
we get to twenty one hundred patrons
tonight number two we have now if you
look at the lower left here we had a two
thousand patron challenge which was when
we get to two thousand patrons I'll do
an entire broadcast show from the studio
with my hair puffed up without product
and we got to 2,000 patrons and I did
that last Monday ok and here's an image
of what that looked like and it was the
stuff of nightmares for a lot of kids
very very scary stuff and kind of scary
to a lot of adults as well but we did it
I made a promise and I stuck to it ok
now if you look at the lower left on our
patreon page instead of saying that the
goal is 2,000 patrons is has 2,500 and
what we're gonna do when we get to 2500
patrons is that we will record edit and
upload my Boston College lectures from
the class that I teach at Boston College
as an adjunct professor along with
slides and visual visuals this is like
15 or 16 hours of content it's academic
content where I talk about critical
thinking I talk about media literacy I
talk about epistemology I talk about
critical thinking and biases and how
that relates I talk about logical
fallacies this is really really good
stuff but it's gonna be a lot of work to
put it together so that's the goal when
we get to 2500 patrons I'm going to do
that and it's going to be an absolute
the fantastic and great thing and then
lastly for every two patreon
contributions I make a move on a Jenga
tower that's been sitting on my desk in
the studio since last year we are
getting down to the end because I'm now
26 moves in and I think at the most I've
got four moves left on this thing
because it is getting both very very
top-heavy and because it is very very
unstable in general okay so I think that
we're getting to the end of that so
really there's like a trifecta of
different things going on with the
patreon stuff and I encourage you to
check that out and get involved get
involved because it is great great stuff
that we are doing and did I have
anything else to say about that
I guess not really christina has sent
the dollar stream lapse contribution I
really enjoyed the cooking video on
Instagram yeah so I this morning I
filmed myself making my breakfast and I
did a little very short video it's I
guess 49 seconds long and I made a I
guess I would call it a breakfast
quesadilla with scrambled eggs and
jalapenos and cilantro and melted cheese
and people seem to like it it's gots one
of my best Instagram videos 1173 views
so far so anyway you can check it out if
you want glad you liked it Christina you
can follow me there David Pakman maybe I
will do well we do another one tomorrow
but I'm having the exact same breakfast
I guess I could just reload the same
video but that'd be lame anyway I don't
know I'll think of something to do jjv
3:45 has sent me a $2.00 stream labs
question asking are you a fan of the WWE
I am NOT I cannot stand what we would
call I guess professional wrestling i I
just I just can't stand it I do believe
though that the Iron Sheik is a
compelling figure he's been making guest
appearances on the Howard Stern Show for
some time
didn't die but he I hope he didn't die
and I didn't hear about it let me see
here
no he's alive and well 75 years old yeah
so I think that there are interesting
characters involved in professional
wrestling but I am NOT a fan of
professional wrestling I just I just
cannot care about it I cannot get myself
to care about it
listen I've talked before that as I get
older and I realize all of the
calamities that humans are are in I find
it harder to even care about sports so
professional wrestling is just very very
low on my list I don't I I wish I had a
different answer if that's what you were
looking for um okay a user going by
Pablo Escobar who is actually just the
person who likes to Google Translate
questions to Inglot to Spanish for me to
read has sent another one of these
questions and I'll read it in Spanish
and then translate it and even as a
native speaker of Spanish it's sometimes
difficult for me to understand what the
hell these questions are about because
of the Google translation this is this
is a dollar contribution look at the
value that this person is getting for a
dollar here we go oh now that we the
gracias thought that I where they hired
maybe read into so Tana so hi David
thanks again for loving letting me live
in your basement of course I have no
basement I live in an apartment building
and the basement is there is no basement
nadia nunca so pitcher acaba solo idea
which is a completely ungrammatical way
of saying no one would ever suspect you
of allowing me to do this por cierto
entrega de perak o Bashar esta noche
hasta seren taun difficile enemy muerto
fin hero pero tu de Foix Subrosa
hasta luego merica so ending with with
the Spanish word for [ __ ]
a very homophobic I didn't know Pablo
Escobar who of course died did I think
1993 was was so homophobic but not
surprised not surprised to hear that man
those those Google Translate spanish
questions are wacky any ghost has sent
the $20 stream lapse contribution what
kind of music do you listen to what are
your favorite bands or songs also pro
tip for your crypto investments people
are expecting the altcoin market to heat
up like oh nice go OMG
neo yeah well let me talk about crypto
in a second I like most music other than
country music I hate country music I
just absolutely despise country music
and really heavy metal I don't like
really heavy metal not a big fan of
bluegrass either but that's kind of
country ish I don't know to the
untrained country ear bluegrass has
overlap with country so I'm into
alternative rock classic rock pop music
I mean really everything right I mean I
some of the bands I like everything from
Led Zeppelin one of my favorite bands
I like Red Hot Chili Peppers 311
Matisyahu sting and the police I've been
to a number of police concerts I used to
love bands in the 90s like the Goo Goo
Dolls and collective soul and live I
don't know I I mean I like a ton of
stuff I like a ton of Argentinian ska
and reggae bands like las peñitas yo-yos
Cadillacs I would then think oh that guy
then there's a lot of a lot of
Argentinian bands that I like as well
now as far as crypto investments my so
yeah I've not made it a secret that I've
been sort of dollar-cost averaging into
Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin over the
last nine months or so I see it as
completely speculative like I'm
considering it lost money that might
someday go up in value but I see crypto
is completely speculative but the other
thing that I am very involved in right
now and I'll actually post a link to
this in the description here for the
live stream is steamin okay steam it is
a blockchain based reddit type website
of content curation and it is a very
very interesting site where I've started
posting content and you can follow me
there I very quickly built up about 500
followers there and I want to build this
thing because I think it has huge
potential money is made on Steam it
would the david pakman show has already
made money on
steam it and we've not invested anything
merely from posting content and curating
content you can make money both ways on
steam it I'm on steam it at David Pakman
so the full address is in the
description its steam it com /at sign
David Pakman follow me there and you'll
see sort of how we're using it it's a
very interesting platform and what's
exciting about it to me is with YouTube
D monetization and Amazon cutting our
affiliate link we need new revenue
sources and this could be an interesting
one is it speculative to some degree it
is but I'm finding it very interesting
so I don't really know much any ghosts
about oMG or neo I don't know how widely
I'm going to diversify my personal
crypto holdings I mean that could
actually I can't I'm not investing
enough money where it makes sense to
split the money among 10 currencies you
know I'm just dollar-cost averaging in a
little bit but check out steam it
because I do think it is very very
interesting as a platform Christina has
sent a dollar stream Labs contribution
have you ever been in a situation where
someone said something in Spanish to you
or about you assuming you would not
understand it yes I have been in
multiple situations like that number one
when I used to work when I was a
fourteen to eighteen before I worked at
Circuit City I worked at a skating rink
and laser tag facility called inter
skate 91 in Hadley Massachusetts and it
would happen there that there would be
Spanish speakers and typically the most
of the spanish-speaking population in
Western Massachusetts is Puerto Rican so
typically it was Puerto Rican folks who
there would be some X conversation with
me about something admission prices or
if I was working the laser tag thing
equipment or something and then they
would say something to each other
insulting me in Spanish and every single
time it's every time it happened I just
loved it I would turn around and I would
say in Spanish something along the lines
of not you're not the only people here
who speak Spanish or we speak Spanish in
Argentina as well or whatever and
if if there were smartphones at the time
this was the late 90s if there had only
been smart phones at the time to record
the expressions on these people faces
these people's faces it was just
something this the stuff of legends I it
hasn't happened for a while and it would
also happen when I was working at
Circuit City actually where there would
be customers that would come in and I
know they speak Spanish right I can tell
they would speak to each other in
Spanish not always very positively about
me sometimes questioning my knowledge of
laptops which was my department I would
sell the laptops and I would say to them
you know if you have specific questions
where you don't think I'm advising you
correctly let me know but I do speak
Spanish and it became very awkward and I
relished the awkwardness I really did it
was it was amazing it was amazing when
that would happen we've got a five
dollar super chat from Mariano Cardozo
who says will you shave your beard and
mustache yeah I will I'm not doing any
kind of like no shaved thing I've just
been lazy about it and this is weeks of
growth I mean my I can barely grow a
beard this is weeks of growth so yeah
I'll probably shave it's just been
laziness tomorrow I'm I've I've got a
lot of stuff in the afternoon and same
thing on Wednesday I don't know when I
will do it but I will do it probably by
the end of the week okay let's see there
was one other I guess it was a stream
labs contribution that came through here
a nameless King sent the dollar a stream
lapse contribution what's the number of
employees for the David Pakman show well
employees is three however we also have
sort of contractors that advise on
really specific things so like motion
graphics contractor who also do work for
other other people right they they have
a number of different clients we've got
that we've got a number of different
volunteers and then we've got you know
our attorney and accountant are not
employees by any means but there's
people involved there's people involved
but formally speaking if the question is
how many w2 employees are there the
answer is three there are currently
three
Pakman show employees vladimir
Alexandrov has sent a $2 stream labs
contribution looking forward to you
releasing your college lectures on
critical thinking given the rise of
disinformation faking using conspiracy
sites like info wars the issue of
identifying and rejecting bad
information is essential thank you so
much yeah that I listen I I think it's
going to be huge I think that when we
when we do release those critical
thinking lectures that it is going to be
a major major thing and it's it's we
were the reason that I'm tying it to the
patreon 2500 patron goal is that it's
just a lot of work I mean we're talking
about 15 hours of content which has to
be synched up with my slides and with
examples video clips all sorts of stuff
these are big projects each lecture is
about 75 bucks so thanks to Cabrera who
just made a $2 a month pledge and
patreon.com slash David Pakman show
we're now at 2079 patrons and when we
get to 2500 we will get to work on those
lectures and in the meantime if we get
to 2100 patrons tonight if we get to
2100 which is just 21 more okay we can
do this right I mean the numbers are
simple if you think that you can't help
if if only like four percent of the
people or six percent of the people
watching right now make a dollar pledge
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll get to 2100 contributions and then
I'll create and release a 55 percent
membership discount code so that that's
what's going on there thanks Vlad Amir
very much appreciated and before I move
on let me also just thank a couple of
other new members I don't want to fall
behind on that thanks to Kevin diesel
Kevin diesel who has signed signed up
Charles treble is a new member at david
pakman.com slash membership - thank you
you are a great great person really
appreciate it and oh I don't think I
mentioned did I mention Michelle
Copeland I don't think I said Michelle
Copeland earlier so thank you - Michelle
Copeland as well really appreciate it
and
yeah what the the support since we've
been dealing with YouTube's D
monetization and the loss of our Amazon
link it's really it's inspiring I don't
know I don't know what else to call it
let me go to a super chat from Chris
Harris who sent a $5 super check do you
think people really believe that news
they don't like his fake news or do you
think they use it as a way to dismiss it
I think it's a mix right it's similar to
regressive left what's big what's going
on with fake news as a term is very
similar to what's going on with
regressive left which is regressive left
was initially developed as a sort of
idea to point out when there are
ostensibly left-wing individuals or
ideas that are actually failing to
actually be progressive and those would
be elements of the regressive left and
it was co-opted by the right to just say
basically anything that's left-wing that
they don't agree with is regressive so
the term became devalued in that sense
fake news really means deliberately
deceptive news or satirical news that's
fake news straight-up fake you know
Obama's a reptilian shapeshifter
Hillary sealed indictment about Hillary
Clinton after you know whatever right
although there's deliberately fake news
that's fake news news you don't agree
with opinion journalism that whose
conclusions you don't agree with that's
not fake news and the term has started
to be used in a way that is a departure
from from what I believe is its actual
meaning but you know fundamentally
language is languages is moldable by
society so in a sense if it's possible
that fake news will come to mean
something different over time but at
least the initial meaning of fake news
is not how it's being used right now
absolutely tomorrow on the program I'm
also going to be talking about there's a
crazy clip from Fox News where Ainsley
Earhardt who is like the resident I
guess Christian apologist on the show
she's all about Jesus
she says that it's a good thing that the
silver lining in the Texas shooting is
that they were in church because there's
no better place to be shot than in
church because you're so close to Jesus
which of course is indicative of pretty
deep mental disturbance if I don't think
that there's any good place to get shot
but if I had to pick one I would say it
would be you know a well-regarded
Hospital would be the best place to get
shot so you can most quickly get help
right so I it's an insane clip from Fox
and Friends that we're going to be
playing for you and there's another
really funny thing that this requires a
bit of explanation so let me let me talk
to you about it remember when President
Obama was president and we would get
unemployment numbers that looked good we
would get job creation numbers that look
good and people on the right would say
record number of people out of the
workforce the labor / labor force
participation rate is in the dumps the
economy is a disaster and at the time I
debunked that and I explained to you
listen there are reasons that the labor
force participation rate can go down
that are indicative of a bad economy and
reasons that are indicative of a good
economy for example if people are coming
to retirement age and the economy is
good they're more likely to be able to
afford retirement and then they are
leaving the labor force so in that case
the labor participation rate going down
would be a positive indicator about the
economy when the economy is better
full-time college students can just
focus on being full-time college
students they don't also need to work
and they are considered in the labor
force participation rate so when the
economy is better and full-time college
students don't need to work it drops the
labor force participation rate but it's
not a sign that the economy is bad so I
debunked it as a terrible way to measure
whether the economy is doing well or not
it just so happens that the labor
participation rate is at a record low we
have a record number of people
we not in the labor force and of course
in the same way that under Obama it
wasn't a good way to evaluate the
economy it's not a good way to evaluate
the economy now but the same Republicans
who were obsessed with labor force
participation conspiracy theories under
Obama are dead and totally silent right
now and it's sort of like the debt and
deficit right it matters when it's a
Democratic president and all of a sudden
it doesn't make a difference when it's a
Republican president whether they want
to pass tax cuts that would explode the
deficit whether they want to pass a tax
or a health care reform plan that will
explode the deficit all of a sudden the
deficit doesn't matter when it's a
Republican in there so we are going to
be talking about that tomorrow and it is
just so obvious that it's never really
about the labor participation rate it's
never really about the dead it's never
really about the deficit it's about
trying to score political points to get
yourself reelected and of course that
applies to both the left and right but
there are some particularly egregious
sort of talking points that are used by
the right which disappear as soon as
they're a guy in this case is in power
so we'll be talking about that tomorrow
and then I will be talking tomorrow
about these bombshell revelations which
show communication between Donald Trump
jr. and WikiLeaks and these are
fascinating for so many reasons number
one the communication that hasn't been
exposed between Donald Trump jr. and
WikiLeaks number one confirms when we
were thinking for months right that you
know WikiLeaks has been functioning more
like a political organization than just
a clearinghouse for leaked documents for
a while it seems as though they may have
some degree of coordination with the
Trump campaign and or Russia or
something like that and of course a lot
of people on the right said that's crazy
David there's absolutely no that that's
bogus it appears that that may be true
and we're gonna be digging into that and
there are a couple articles that you can
check out about this online but these
are blockbuster revelations and I think
that they are going to be fleshing out
the
the broader story that we are following
here in terms of Trump Russia so that
we're going to talk about that on the
program tomorrow and I think it's a
really important story and of course
there will be people who say it's all
fake news and how it all fake right just
doesn't really make any sense any ghost
has sent the $20 screen lapse
contribution would you interview stefan
molyneux on the topic of race and IQ
he's always interviewing academics that
hold the perspective that blacks are
intellectually inferior and I think a
collaboration video between you two
could expose his audience to new
perspectives I would be willing to talk
to him about that and on that note I
have a big big announcement which is the
race and IQ video that we have been
working on for a while now is complete
it is in its final touch-ups right now
segment producer Noah Ferguson is
finalizing it and it is going to be
published Monday okay
a week from today Monday on the
broadcast show we will have part one on
Monday part two on Tuesday it's about a
half hour long this is a doozy and it is
not for the faint of heart we are going
to go deep on this one into race and IQ
part one Monday part two Tuesday the
entire 30 minute piece will be available
on YouTube sometime next week and I
think you're going to like it
it's it's an absolutely tremendous piece
meticulously researched and I look
forward to bringing it to you because
we've been I know I've been teasing it
for a while and we've not had a lot of
long-form pieces lately specifically
because we have been working on the race
and IQ piece and it's going to be really
good so to answer the question I would
be willing to talk to stefan molyneux
about that issue of course I'm not an
expert on that issue right I go to the
academics on that issue and you know we
talk about a lot of the supposed
academics that Stefan Molyneux talks
about and I saw his interview with Dave
Rubin recently about this issue and it
was just an absolute and total abortion
I mean just absolutely in
and anyway I guess that's all I have to
say about race and IQ right now but we
will be publishing that piece soon and
it's going to be a very very good piece
okay on that note I'm going to cut
today's stream a little short a lot of
research to do for tomorrow's program
thanks to everybody for joining me
helped us get to those 2500 patrons when
we do do that there will be even crazier
things than this even crazier things
than this will happen alright thanks to
everybody